I'm so happy to talk to
you, Patton, God bless you.
Yeah, that's just, trust me,
this interview has been a lifeline for me,
this has been like
holding concert tickets.
I've known about it for a
couple of weeks and it's like,
"If I can just get to Tuesday
morning and talk to Conan."
(both laugh)
This is, no, seriously,
I was coming to the
theater today to tape this
and I was thinking, "Oh
great, I'm so starved
to talk to funny people,"
and you're one of my favorite people,
and I was like, "I get
to talk to Patton today."
And so I think I drove 80 miles an hour
to get to the theater, just
so we can have this interview.
Let's make this about you
and then more about me.
Yes.
How are you doing during isolation?
Are you handling this all right?
And why are you sitting in
a Loews Theater right now?
(chuckles) Look,
when the shelter-in-place order came down,
I was in the early
screening of "Black Widow".
(Conan laughs)
No spoilers, like you know,
I'm just, I've been in place
and you can live on Red Vines and Sprite.
People don't understand this,
but it's a very intense diet.
So you'd been saying that
they shouted COVID quarantine
while the movie was ending,
and you just said, "I'll just stay here."
I go, "Yeah," I was,
at well, first I thought is this part,
is this the next phase
of the Marvel movies
where they actually add some
kinda outside threatening?
Oh no, it's really real,
and I'm kind of the last one left here,
a lot of us have gone insane.
There's one other guy,
but he's living under the seats now.
So it's just, I'm kind
of the spokesman, it's...
(Conan laughs)
They said you, you will
speak for all of us here
at the abandoned theater.
I mean, I've been handling things okay.
I realized the other day that
a lot of times in the morning
I will go sit on my front porch.
We have like a front porch swing,
and I'll sit out there and read a book
and the same people will go walking by
and I'm starting to worry
that I'm becoming the weird
fixture in the neighborhood.
The guy in his robe and cargo shorts
just kinda waving at people with a book
and they use me as a, "Oh it's,
well, it's 9:00 a.m, he's out there."
Like I'm the weird
neighborhood clock now to tape
and to step things by,
but I've become a guy
who sits on his front
porch and waves at people.
Right, right, yes.
The thing you as a child or as a teenager,
you thought I'll never be that guy, ever.
Yes, that, oh my God,
I'm the guy, no I am,
I'm the guy in slasher
movie at the beginning
who's like, "That house
has a death curse."
And like, "Shut up. (mumbles)"
(Conan laughs)
Like I'm, oh god, I turned into that guy.
Yes, you're that guy,
"Oh, you don't wanna go
up there, I tell ya."
"Don't go to the old beards lay place,
it's a murder house,"
and they're, "Shut up."
(chuckles) You know what I'm missing now,
a hair and makeup team.
I am missing a hair and makeup team.
When, okay, first off your
hair, they should take,
they should use time-lapse
photos, that should be
the chronicle of this
quarantine, it's Conan's hair.
The ongoing, like the, the
bigger and bigger it gets.
When this quarantine ends,
every actor and actress,
we should organize
some massive dinner celebration parade
just for hair and makeup people.
They should be, whenever we see them,
we should like avert our gaze and kneel.
Yes, yes.
They are so clearly such a crucial,
they're beyond crucial in show business.
I mean, we knew that they
were valuable, but my God,
the next, whatever the next
live Academy Award should be,
there should be, they should like have a,
they should like bring a
powder puff out on stage,
we should all like stand
and just kind of worship it.
Just like
(Conan laughs)
bow our heads down and (mumbles)
some kind of this shining thing.
Right.
Oh my God,
hair and makeup people,
I've always tried to be nice to you,
but I was not being nice enough.
I promise you, this is,
I'm gonna show up in
that trailer every day
with muffins and coffee
and just, thank you.
No, I've been frightening people online
with my hair everyday on the show,
because every day, like some days
I kinda comb it up a little bit,
but it's gotten so long.
[Patton] Jesus.
There's like nine feet of hair
and then it turns into this tsunami.
But then if I let it go, it comes down
and I sort of look like,
"Hey man, I'm just playing my song, man."
And I'm pushing my hair back this way
and yeah, it's, but I'm
just sort of enjoying
letting it all go, just let it all go.
Yeah, if you didn't have any product
in your hair right now,
you would look like the
one viking on the raid
that like knows what all the,
like the codes and codexes mean,
like there's the big
brawny guys who are like,
"No, this means there'd be dragons,"
listen to like, you're
the guy they bring along-
Wait a minute, so I'm not
the good fighter or the strong Viking.
I'm the guy that's like,
"I know the signs."
Well, no, they bring
you along to translate
like so they make sure they
don't open any cursed items,
that's who they bring on.
[Conan] Thanks a lot.